this was novak djokovic maskless and
shaking hands as he unveiled a new stamp
of himself in serbia on december the
16th the same day he tested positive for
culvert for a second time
the next day he appears to have attended
an awards ceremony at his own tennis
center in belgrade presenting trophies
to more than 20 young players
documents filed by his legal team reveal
he was granted a temporary visa by
australian authorities on november the
18th
on december 30th he received a letter
from tennis australia's chief medical
officer confirming his exemption from
vaccination on the grounds he had
recently recovered from covert and on
new year's day they claim he received
notification from the australian
department of home affairs that he met
the requirements for quarantine free
arrival into the country
the defending australian open champion
is spending a third night at this
immigration detention center in
melbourne a city that has endured one of
the longest and most stringent lockdowns
in the world if he's got natural
immunity there's no reason why he needs
to be essentially locked up in a what we
think is a detention center if the rules
are that you need to be double
vaccinated to enter this country then
that should apply equally to everyone
some observers feel that with a federal
election looming here djokovic's
situation has become an opportunity for
political point scoring it appears to me
that mr djokovic has received
significantly unfair treatment
he's landed in the middle of a
major political dispute
which
is in the lead up to a federal election
in australia the political party
leaders
are taking pot shots at each other
the czech player renato voracova also
had har visa cancelled having already
spent a week in australia and played a
match and have been held at the same
center
she has now left australia on a flight
to dubai
when novak got on the plane there were
already players here in australia with
the same exemptions
allowed through the border allowed to be
in australia and then also know that
it's on the plane
the federal government gets a poll out
that says 75 percent of australians are
not happy with them coming into the
country and with an election coming up
this year i think that the federal
government will like maybe this is the
time for us to sort of prove a bit of a
point
back home in belgrade the djokovic
family held a rally in support of their
son's demand to be allowed into
australia
serbia's prime minister has spoken to
australia's foreign minister to ask that
fitness equipment gluten-free food a
laptop and sim card are delivered to
djokovic's room
there is only one court that matters now
for the 20-time grand slam winner a
judge in melbourne will decide on monday
whether novak djokovic can stay and
defend his title or be deported ender
brady sky news